on c-span too
ladies and gentlemen Shakespeare Theatre
Company bard Association's annual dinner
and Mock Trial before we begin the trial
please take this time to silence all
electronic devices that may disrupt this
evenings proceedings photography of
tonight's trial is strictly prohibited
please join me in welcoming STC trustee
and chair of the bard Association Abbi
David Lowell good evening thanks for
joining us tonight
to the annual dinner and Mock Trial
event presented by the Shakespeare
Theatre Company and its bard Association
the affinity group of lawyers those
associated with the legal community and
those who support the legal community to
bring the best that we can to the stage
of this wonderful theater as you know
tonight's performance
tonight's trial is based on the
production of 1984 that was presented by
the Shakespeare Theatre Company a few
short months ago and which in turn is
based on the 1949 that's right
1949 book by George Orwell predicting
what 1984 might look like I know you all
know the story very well a completely
far-fetched story where a country's
government vacuums up enormous amounts
of data about its citizens in the name
of national security where a country's
leader works hard to keep the people
scared and divided to prevent newcomers
and serious opposition by among other
techniques encouraging people to have
daily sessions where they yell their
anger and their hate against anyone who
disagrees with them and where the
opposition creates a sort of resistance
by installing an offline communication
system not in the mainframe of the
government to protect private
communications
hmm maybe not so far-fetched at the
conclusion of tonight's argument you're
going to be asked to serve as the jury
and vote on the following question given
the context of war and the threat to
national security should the Oceania
officials named as defendants in Winston
Smith's lawsuit be held liable for their
treatment of Winston Smith in 1984 if
you believe that these officials should
not be held liable please vote with a
red token that you were given for know
if you believe the Oceania officials
should be held liable vote with a blue
token for yes and I would now like to
introduce to you and welcome tonight's
participants please join me and
welcoming supreme court marshal Pamela
Talton
and please welcome to the stage counsel
to petitioner Winston Smith ami Jeffers
from the law firm of Arnold and Porter
[Applause]
and now counsel for the respondent the
state of Oceania Bob Bauer of Perkins
Kui
and of course the members of the
esteemed bench of the Supreme Court of
the state of Oceania Supreme Court
Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg presiding
justice Steven G Breyer Judge David
Tatel judge Patricia Millett and Judge
Cornelia Pilar
enjoy
oyez oyez oyez the Supreme Court of
Oceania is now in session
please be seated and welcome to 1984 as
perceived by people living in 2016 we'll
hear first from the petitioner
represented by Amy Jefferies thank you
your honor and may it please the court
my co-counsel Sally Pei and I represent
our client Winston Smith mr. Smith is
not present this evening however and we
understand that he may have been
vaporized which goes straight to the
first point of our argument
there is a clear threat of irreparable
injury in this case which is why this
court must enjoin the state from the
unlawful practices of Big Brother that
president Freeman promised to end what
injury Winston Smith has already been
wrongfully arrested detained
interrogated and tortured and now
possibly vaporized further he like all
other citizens is subject to the state's
constant unwarranted surveillance as
George Orwell wrote a party member lives
from birth to death under the eye of the
thought police the state of life in
Oceania is literally Orwellian the
alleged national security reasons for
the state's policies are vastly
overblown the state has not identified
any concrete information collected
through its intrusive surveillance that
has been useful in defending national
security to the contrary so far this
surveillance has only been used to
ensure that Oceania citizens are using
the appropriate bathrooms
[Music]
[Applause]
that's right the state is surveilling
its citizens solely to enforce the birth
sex bathroom statutes known of course by
their acronym BS BS
and how is the state conducting this
surveillance we understand that the
state has pushed malware to all cell
phones tablets and computers in Oceania
and has unfettered access to encrypted
data and cameras on any device in
Oceania these policies your honors will
not make Oceania great again which is
what the thought police might claim so
the era of Big Brother is not over as
president Freeman has promised which
leads me to our second argument the
officers responsible for the harm move
on ms Jeffress president freeman could
be making a lot of money running casinos
or reality TV programs or or giving
private speeches to investment bankers
instead he cares enough to be our
president devoted totally to taking care
of the people so it really seems like
pure conjecture that the thoughtful
police would abuse the powers of
observation they have only to keep us
safe
he cares about only one thing your honor
and that is his own power because you
have introduced a threshold question you
have asked for sanctions to be set by
this court for service Lee gaining
access to your preliminary briefs you
did not identify what sanctions you
sought and you did not tell us what was
in those briefs
that you disclaim so if you would
respond to those threshold questions
what sanctions and what do you now
disclaim that was in your prior reefs
Your Honor we merely disclaim our prior
briefs in order to protect the sanctity
of the attorney-client privilege we we
knew that the state was monitoring all
of our communications as we all know so
we did not write anything that we
thought would be would be damaging if
released because we all know that we are
live under constant surveillance but we
did move for sanctions because we
believe that it's important for this
court to acknowledge that the state has
abused its authority and that the
malware that is infecting all of our
devices is improper and must be must be
enjoined sanctions we would like
monetary damages of course and we would
like to enjoin the state from any
further intrusive surveillance of our
client and of all citizens of Oceania
one more preliminary question I and all
of my colleagues were appointed by
President Freeman that much so do you
think that you can gain impartial
justice this Tribunal
now I understand that president Freeman
is in his last term in office so would
you move that we hold this whole
proceeding in abeyance that is an
excellent question your honor but I had
not thought of but quite brilliantly but
no your honor
I am confident that we can get a fair
hearing from this bench I would note
that approximately half of you have
previously worked for the ACLU which is
an affiliate of course of the Oceania
Civil Liberties Union and we believe
that we can get a fair hearing from
these judges and so we thank you for the
question but only this court your honor
can protect the rights of Winston Smith
and the other citizens of Oceania well I
know counsel you expressed concern about
surveillance and its intrusion on your
work and I just wanted to assure you
that there are and will not be any
cameras in the Supreme Court here
Oh miss miss Jeffers I want to ask you
to focus on your argument about about
qualified immunity and I want to ask you
the question that I think is actually
key to this case
good thinking officers beli felt in
shock and if Merriman double-plus on in
thoughtful
how could Murray Minh be clear wise
established you don't speak you speak
your honor speaks excellent do speak o
employers like for you your honor that
does you look um answer the question in
either honesty
thank you your honor for the benefit of
the reasonable officers understood and
live the principles of English socialism
and Merryman is entirely countered of
that principle how could a reasonable
officer possibly know the rule of that
case in other words okay well your honor
[Laughter]
for the benefit of the audience I will
respond in English Thank You Winston
Smith's rights to be free from wrongful
arrest interrogation torture and
unjustified surveillance were all
well-established at the time the
officers mistreated him the Constitution
is still in force in Oceania
despite the laws that big brother has
brought into play no reasonable officer
could have believed that it was lawful
to subject Winston Smith to routine
beatings and psychological torture I
really have a preliminary question here
mr. jeffris how can you say that your
client faced a threat of irreparable
harm I mean he can't even show standing
you've read our claptrap decision your
your argument seems to rest on on a mere
chain of contingencies without any kind
of risk that is certainly impending just
because the state has surveillance power
to the I Patriot Act to monitor every
last communication of its subjects
doesn't mean the government will
actually use those powers Your Honor is
correct that the court in the claptrap
case did find that the plaintiffs there
had only a speculative claim of harm as
a result of the government's
surveillance practices here however
Winston Smith can demonstrate that the
government intends to inspect his cell
phone and likely far worst arrests
detain and torture him though it is
worth noting that the dissenters in
clapper were certainly correct that the
plaintiffs there were virtually certain
intercepted and monitored but we need
not rely on their dissent because the
majority's ruling does not bind the
court on these significantly very
different facts to intervene at the
preliminary injunction stage why
shouldn't we wait till a full record is
developed that the permanent injunction
stays why should we proceed on a skimpy
record rather than everything you want
to plug in your honor Winston Smith and
the citizens of Oceania need immediate
relief and only this court can provide
that relief and it must be done right
away we would note that there is no
national security threat as as we have
said big brother claims that war is
peace when the fictitious war is merely
a pretext to maintain the repressive
social order and the party's grip on
power don't you have a serious causation
problem that we need to establish a
record for and I know in particular you
argue in your brief that the parties
systematically destroyed and continuing
with President Freeman systematically
destroyed the people's capacity for
independent analysis and critical
thought but as I think about causation I
wonder whether keeping up with the
kardashians and other reality TV
had already done that to us we are all
suffering on a regular basis Your Honor
that's a perfect example well you know
there's a man who wrote about what you
say was done and the name of that man
was Hambleton and before I can say you
should get your way I want to know what
that man did say
[Applause]
your honor
if Hamilton were here I know he would
say that the defendants in this case the
thought police should be held liable for
their illegal mistreatment of Winston
Smith our founding fathers would not
have tolerated the abusive authorities
that big brother has brought to the
state of Oceania I don't know I have a
question about the record in this case
both sides have experience with
rewriting history the government through
its truth Department and that's where
Winston Smith wrote I work write
rewriting history
he worked in many child can we have any
confidence that anything either side is
telling us it's true Your Honor the
court must be referring to doublethink
among other concepts the power of
holding two contradictory beliefs in
one's mind simultaneously and accepting
both of them and Oceania slogan war is
peace is premise on Big Brother's
indoctrination of its citizens in
doublethink which we are all suffering
from I also know that you rely you rely
on the case called ex parte Merriman
that was written by Chief Justice Taney
who also wrote the Dred Scott decision
if he's really a reliable source for
Seoul Liberties principles we like the
ex parte Merriman case because the
plaintiff won
[Laughter]
I think that case was about suspension
of the writ of habeas corpus and why
isn't that strictly academic in this
case because whether it's executive or
the legislature the legislature in
oceania is under the thumb of the
executive that is correct your honor and
my opponent relies on the Silence of
Congress as assent by Congress and we
would argue that we cannot rely on
Congress to protect the rights of the
citizens of ASEAN I would see that
differently I mean hasn't Congress
effectively acquiesced in the
unconstrained presidential powers that
the president Freeman is exercising here
I mean Congress hasn't acted
meaningfully in years the government
leaders care so much for the people's
safety that they have almost nothing but
safe seats left in Congress that is
exactly right justice pillared and that
is why we rely on this court for the
relief that Winston Smith seeks yeah but
those actions of which you are
complaining so they happened 32 years
ago are you discriminating against those
with age
isn't there a time when we turn the page
[Applause]
Your Honor the thought police like all
officials are presumed to have knowledge
and respect for basic unquestioned
constitutional rights as set forth by
our founding fathers to be free from
unlawful arrest detention and torture
miss Jeffords I have another question
about qualified immunity which I will
ask you in English you say in your brief
quote nothing was illegal since there
were no longer any laws it's a quote
from your brief doesn't that mean that
no law could have been clearly
established that is a concern that we
have with the entire concept of
qualified immunity in this case your
honor is that there is no rule of law in
a state like Oceania again we would
submit that only this court can restore
the rights of the citizens of Oceania
so in conclusion your honors we insist
that the defendants the thought police
be held liable for their illegal
mistreatment of Winston Smith they must
be held liable no other outcome is
consistent with the Constitution the
vision of the founding fathers that
Justice Breyer has so articulately
quoted and not sung and no other outcome
is consistent with justice I don't know
miss Jeffers your whole argument seems
premise on the idea that we're in some
kind of dystopian science fiction police
state or something the scenario is 1984
right but you're asserting a privacy
right and and I checked and your client
is all over Google and Facebook and
Twitter and Instagram and snapchat and
for this audience LinkedIn
and he even posted selfies with LeBron
James is my understanding and so what
what privacy right is left what wouldn't
you have to concede that Apple Google
and Facebook know more about him than
the state could ever learn your honor
that is an excellent point our client
however did try to lead a private life
and tried to have a relationship with a
lover in the state that he was unable to
have because of the state's intrusive
surveillance so there is privacy which
he sought and in addition your honor I
would note that through the malware that
the state has placed on all of our
devices it's impossible to know whether
all of the social media was truly
originated by Winston Smith or has been
placed there by the many true the
Ministry of Truth for which he worked in
which he and others regularly used to
transmit propaganda to support the
state's repressive regime and I also
noted that in your opponent's brief they
made some mention and footnote 5 of
practices in foreign countries but you
didn't you seem to focus only on
domestic law and are you aware that
Justice Breyer just published a book
called the court in the world American
law and the new global reality are you
disrespecting his views of the law I am
aware of the book your honor and would
never disrespect Jessica but did you
read the book
I bought the book you're the one
[Laughter]
I don't understand I don't understand
how you can prevail here given Winston
Smith's own description of his condition
after his reeducation by the state he
said quote that he quote longed Big
Brother but he understood that the party
had helped him quote win the victory
over himself this seems to be a happy
contentment what's he complaining about
Your Honor the state also argues that
Winston Smith's problems are of his own
making that he is a victim only of his
own mind but if someone is someone
paranoid if everyone truly is out to get
him as the state clearly is in this case
this is the case for Winston Smith he is
the victim the state criticizes his very
thoughts and how is the state aware of
these private thoughts through its
constant unlawful unrelenting
surveillance exactly the practice that
Smith challenges today precisely I mean
we might as well dismiss now Smith's
case if I'm understanding you correctly
asserts a reasonable expectation of
privacy the essence of which is his
unwillingness to show everything so
hasn't he effectively pled himself out
of court because an unwillingness to
share everything via iphone is contrary
to the I Patriot Act
he would not be showing everything
through his iPhone if the state did not
have it infected by malware to make its
every communication available to the
state well what about his Facebook post
everything's out there right but why do
you have private what is your line about
between privacy what you're sharing on
social media and what you want to share
with the state why can't the state find
out too in oceania Winston Smith is not
free to share his own posts because the
thought police and the Ministry of Truth
control everything and I would like to
reserve the remaining five minutes of my
time for rebuttal
and we will now hear from counsel for
Oceana Bob Bauer madam Chief Justice and
if as we strongly recommend it please
the court
petitioner paints Oceania as lawless
what then is this legal proceeding
judge's council case all open to the
public except the unfortunates who could
not afford the ticket price all the
world can see that this Smith with his
violent criminal history is now free to
be a litigant and this transition is the
hallmark of a rule of law society
petitioner claims he has been lawlessly
tortured but he grounds that in a record
that is replete with paranoia it's so
1984 everybody's out to get him a state
officials are whispering cryptically to
him in hallways and we say oh please he
also says that our surveillance program
is sure to land him in prison but how
can he know that why would we not have
done it before now before this spectacle
and put him away quietly sparing him
unimaginable legal expense the court
will note our moderation to defend
against East Asia and Eurasia we
proposed reasonably to build an
incredible wall and have them pay for it
that they refused is not our fault now
petitioner says he should be able to sue
the officials who interrogated him for
damages citing ex parte Merriman ex
parte Merriman that one-man show of
brute judicial force rightly resisted by
the heroic Lincoln yes
Lincoln arrested and exiled opposition
yes he shut down newspapers but like our
aptly named President Freeman he
committed that these measures would be
temporary so when petitioner visits that
marble memorial out by the reflecting
pool that each year attracts hundreds of
thousands of visitors and pigeons what
does he imagine that he sees the tawny
memorial no we stand with Lincoln and
with the officers who acted on the
authority of the order issued in the
constitutional tradition that he forged
so allow me to
now in the words of Shakespeare when
this thief this traitor who all the
while half reveled in the night shall
see us rising in our throne his treason
will sit blushing in his face not able
to endure the sight of day but self
affrighted tremble at his sin or to put
it more simply deny the claims we'll
take it from there have made some pretty
strong arguments against Winston Smith
but as I read your argument we seem to
be saying that no one has standing to
object to what is going on in Oceania
your threshold argument is there is no
standing go away who does have standing
well surely somebody who has not already
been vaporized has standing they can
hardly be standing if they are a vapor
I think
so anyone anyone who has not yet been
vaporized that's pending well it's a
good start
just as kids and everybody is subject to
this 24/7 surveillance so among those
everybody who can sue well as you know
the cellphones were equipped with a
device that is activated only upon the
application of certain criteria the
petitioner doesn't know what these
criteria are does not cite them and has
no reason to believe that he will be
arrested because of their application so
we would have to have a petitioner
coming in saying here are the reasons
why I'm confident the cell phone will be
turned on and I will be followed and
we're quite confident you're right chief
justice nobody's going to have the nerve
to come in and say that I think your
your argument that the risk of harm to
Smith is conjectural really proves too
much because in your view even thinking
about this lawsuit made Smith guilty of
thought crimes
once he filed it you either have to go
after him or admit they you don't really
care what people think and if the
government doesn't care what people
think how can it defend the total
surveillance regime under the I Patriot
Act Oh judge Pollard the government
cares profoundly what people think or we
wouldn't be equipping the cell phones
with these surveillance devices mr.
Bauer I don't have a news a new state
question for you frankly I couldn't
figure out how to question the
government in a language deliberately
designed to make questioning the
government impossible so I want to ask
you this about surveillance you say in
your brief that Smith re-education makes
it quote less likely under any rational
targeting criteria then he'll be
surveilled that's from your brief but I
don't see how that's consistent with
Oceanos pre 1984 policy reeducate
returning them to the population and
later making them disappear the O'Brien
told Winston in the end
we shall shoot you well I should point
out to you judge Tatel that the record
shows that by the end of the book
Winston Smith is still very much with us
and though counsel today chose not to
appear with him he's represented there
must somewhere be an engagement letter
[Laughter]
you mean Lincoln the President or
Lincoln the automobile I meant the one
that runs in compliance with all
applicable safety standards imposed by
the state of Oceania my other question
was that how do you turn on its
cellphone anyway I'm not good I'm sorry
you how does he turn on his no how do I
turn on when I've been trying to turn
hard you don't have to worry about that
at all judge Breyer Justice Breyer we're
gonna turn it on for you when we please
I thought through your brief and some of
you argument here you're actually really
understating the level of intrusion it's
not just the monitoring through the
phones but isn't it true that you
recently had dropped at a so-called
Metro safe track program that's designed
to keep us all trapped in our homes for
the next year so you can monitor us more
closely
[Applause]
jug's Milan I didn't hear all your
questions because they're not really mob
what you're not responsible for the
traffic in this city are you the Metro
safe track program that keeps everybody
locked in their homes did you start that
it's entirely a pilot project no but I'm
getting very interested now I think it's
this is a why did you you why are you
doing all these things we're doing what
is necessary to protect the state of
Oceania against the threats that
petitioners himself admitted to
committing what kinds of threats the
threat of internal insurgency the threat
of aid to our enemy the threat that that
book would go on and on and on my book
[Laughter]
no Justice Breyer but I'd like to speech
you afterwards about the audio version
why Winston Smith he's already been in
vaporized what about the popular refrain
we did it before and we can do it again
that common sense understanding that
particularly well think about the sexual
offender registration law the whole
premise is if you did it once you're
likely to do it again so Winston mrs.
Smith's position is the state did it
before they are likely to do it again
but what mr. Smith doesn't account for
is that we have a rigorous reeducation
program that as you know we have funded
the race to the bottom and our goal
there was to provide what we call a Gore
curriculum the effect of which is to
make sure that when mr. Smith emerges
he's a changed in better man the very
contented man the judge Tatel has
identified so correctly in the book I
want to follow up on justice Ginsburg's
question though because I mean she asked
you why you're going after this poor man
Winston Smith I want to know why the
government isn't trying to surveil Ohio
he's a far more he's a far greater
danger to the state after all he
literally wrote Goldstein's book which
implies blatant thoughtcrime he's far
more dangerous yet you're not yet easier
client well O'Brien's not my client
though he authorizes the payment of my
bills
I don't think therefore I'm most
responsive to him your honor but what I
will but what I want to say about that
is O'Brien O'Brien doesn't admit to the
authorship of that book that book is a
thinly guys tract Goldstein of a vol nom
de Moz democracy and dictatorship by
Leon Trotsky and it advocates the most
violent methods to use to unsettle a
democracy so O'Brien in fact is part of
the solution and not all at all part of
the problem why wasn't Julia prosecuted
that's my question did she play the
woman card
Your Honor Oceania is a merciful state
that applies the law on the specific
facts there was no indication she was
anything other than someone who in love
with this man had been induced to enter
into the conspiracy that's what I mean
it's ashamed to say the Oceania lacks
the rule of law when it's brimming over
with that kind of empathy question about
rule of law in Oceania it seems that the
legitimacy of Freeman's administration
depends on the people believing that by
winning the election they won back some
of their civil liberties and I was a
little confused by you saying that
O'Brien is your client I thought you're
representing the state and not the
individual defendants and I think you're
really missing an opportunity here right
so you could have those the illusion of
the rule of law and do whatever you want
if you just pin it on the individual
defendants like why are you even here
with the qualified immunity appeal
Oceania says oh it's all their fault not
ours but but you're here appealing let
the you know avoid liability for the
freeman administration and and let the
individuals take the fall isn't that
core that sounds very appealing thank
you for suggesting it
rewind and start all over again that's
very good yes but how could how can you
possibly claim qualified immunity for
the individual defendants in the case
like this I mean we do have a
Constitution it's stipulated it's still
in force are you asking us on qualified
immunity to forget about the remember
principle your honor as you know we've
adopted the United States Constitution
that isn't to say we fully believe in it
we're adapting it to current conditions
but one thing we know for sure is that
the executive order pursuant to which
these officials acted was well known for
years there's no reason to believe they
thought it was anything other than
lawful there's no reason for us to hold
those lower on the totem pole
responsible for the errors or the
misdeeds of the higher up and the higher
up in turn could never be prosecuted for
their misdeeds because they're not
capable of committing them setting aside
the executive order that you just
mentioned in response to justice
Ginsburg's question would you at least
concede that a reasonable officer would
have known that it was unlawful to put
on Smith's face a wire cage full of rats
yeah first of all I would answer in two
parts number one I would say that we
have no eye testimony other than Smith's
own for that particular episode that you
cite but even if it's true I mean
everybody's a critic
how far does the state go in the
emergency palace that it is claiming I
mean it has committed detention of
people torture of people torture is okay
in a time of terror is that your
position no Chief Justice Ginsburg
that's not our petition our position at
all there as anybody who's attended
Middle School in the United States knows
there's a thin line between re-education
and torture it's really it's really a
matter of nomenclature more than
anything else if there is how do you
define it
I have heard presidential debates this
year that going along for three and a
half hours your honor that I would
characterize his torture yes you claim
the prerogative to suspend habeas corpus
but isn't it the case that only the
legislature can suspend habeas corpus
I'm I'm just trying to understand
whether you're contending that
Congress's inability to fulfill even the
most basic functions textually assigned
to it such as vison consent gives the
president powers that ordinarily would
rest with the Congress
well your honor I would say this
Congress has not been inactive it took a
enormous amount of work and political
will to produce a suppressive statute
like AI Patriot so when it needs to rise
to the occasion it does so I hear it was
so long that nobody actually even read
it before it was an active that includes
the members who passed it yes your honor
yes your honor and so I don't think it's
an accurate statement either that we're
saying Congress had no role in the
suspension of habeas as in the Lincoln
example we gave you earlier Congress in
that instance acted only years after
Lincoln ignored judge Taney and here we
have a whole period of congressional
acquiescence
Your Honor acquiescence is far better
than gridlock and this is does your
answer to judge pillar does that rest on
a document from the truth Department oh
precisely that's my case we the point I
made with your co-counsel and I want to
ask you exactly here your miss Jeffers
is that you represent a government that
wants me in a truth department where you
rewrote history president Friedman has
continued some of the most draconian
provisions and policies of Big Brother
how do we have any confidence how do we
have any basis for believing that the
rewriting of history policies of Big
Brother are not continuing and therefore
how could we rely on anything you've
told us today well I'd like to respond
to that judge Tatel because I think it's
an important point
that's why yes you did yes you did and
what I would like to stress is that I
think as in the thin line and discussed
earlier one should not confuse lying or
deception with public relations and
smart public relations strategies what
Smith did what Smith did is known in
this town is spin a kind of violent
variety but it's spin it's been it's not
lies but you did as you heard but all
you know minor things like rats and so
forth on the person's a cage or wherever
he was and they're a whole bunch of
things they're pretty bad and you're
saying it was really the higher-ups and
not these clients so why don't we indict
the higher-ups or would you consider
that judicial activism
Your Honor as I said earlier I think
it's very difficult to find higher-ups
in Oceania who are doing anything other
than their level best to protect the
country but one thing we know whatever
the record that shows about those
misdeeds and President Freeman may well
be committed to pursuing prosecution of
those higher-ups this case is about
Smith and Smith is a fevered paranoid
discontent who was glad to draw a salary
from the Ministry of Truth until
everything went apart on him and we re
educated him and he has been permitted
to leave and he has a lawyer and if
you're allowed to go free and you are
represented by counsel in this country
than all constitutional guarantees of
any meaning have built and fulfilled I
don't have that impression from the
record I did have a different impression
but if it's presidencies continuing this
policy
why don't we impeach President Freeman -
I mean if there is no law why can't we
just be activists well as I said to you
earlier Justice Breyer if there's no law
what are we doing here is this a
fundraising event
[Laughter]
[Applause]
as stipulated that we have a
constitution what constitutional rights
does Smith have does he have First
Amendment rights
does he have Fourth Amendment rights
does he have eight Amendment rights does
he have any of those who second right
yes yes yes he absolutely does Chief
Justice Ginsburg and there's no question
whatsoever we embrace the United States
Constitution and anytime that mr. Smith
wants some exposure to those rights he's
free to inspect them they're enclosed
within glass at the National Archives
I'm not sure that this is relevant to
the case before us but I just can't
resist the opportunity since we have you
here I understand that in Oceania two
plus two equals five and I wonder is
that code for a gun plus a gun equals
due process
[Applause]
that I think your honor is the new math
that has been created by voter rage did
the rats on the face where one thing but
didn't you really cross the line into
clearly unconstitutional cruel and
unusual punishment when you made a meet
Trump steaks
[Applause]
quite the contrary your honor they are
the very best steaks found anywhere as
you know we also offered him an
opportunity to present to have the
steaks with a book we supply called art
of the meal mr. mr. Bauer I want to
assure you that given the Code of
Judicial Conduct which the freeman
administration has reenacted this is not
a judge Tatel under the holding of
Williams versus you Lee you are probably
right theory about the Constitution's
place in a time of terror and it's known
as the deckchair theory of
constitutional rights that is when the
sun is shining when we are at peace we
have all the constitutional rights that
we could have but when the storm clouds
gather the deck chairs are folded up and
all the rights go away
is that your the view that you're trying
to get this court to accept that
constitutional rights are for sunshine
and not a stormy weather no Chief
Justice Ginsburg not at all if I can
liken it for example to a domed baseball
stadium most people like to watch
baseball in the open air with a bright
and sunny blue sky but every now and the
weather interferes and in some
jurisdictions when this is a major and
ongoing problem they close the roof but
the game of baseball continues that's I
think appropriately
his leading analogy
[Laughter]
well are you listening on his are you
listening to mr. Strong's cell phone or
are you not are we listening to mr.
Smith cell phone mr. Smith that's a
problem well he'd no our impression is
that it was vaporized along with him
we're not getting a signal to be honest
Justice Breyer alright so is it legal to
vaporize people well if they're not
working we see no harm in that good
point other countries to determine
whether that's a disproportionate
punishment other countries foreign
countries to decide whether vaporization
is a disproportionate and cruel and
unusual punishment the problem we have
is there only 3 countries on the face of
the earth and the other two are our
mortal enemies so we'd have to be very
cautious about misdirection on their
part no you forgot the country of a
pouria oh yes that's that's covered in
your book Justice Breyer thank you I had
one other question for you and that is
really whether this is your means are
disproportionate to the end if you want
to get inside of our cell phones do we
really need to authorize the government
to do it can't most teenagers do it
well yes your honor but your wish is
fulfilled the government is currently
being run by teenagers in conclusion in
conclusion petitioner has come here or
not in fact because he's no longer with
us to claim that he has standing he does
not have standing he does not have
standing and he should not be here
attempting to suggest that this state in
this courtroom in this legal proceeding
with this public in attendance is in any
way lawless were merely meeting the
demands of the moment the best that we
can and as I said earlier we stand in
the tradition of some of our greatest
presidents who have had to take these
steps in times of crisis thank you
miss Jefferson I think you have five
minutes five minutes remaining thank you
your honor
my opponent I would like to thank my
opponent for his eloquence argument
today and for the fact that he has
conceded the critical point which is
that he need not defend the individual
officers in this case he is representing
Big Brother and leaving the individual
officers out to dry okay I just say that
I am a little tired of all these
references to Big Brother isn't it time
to break the glass ceiling and have a
big sister
[Music]
many of us in the audience would like to
think that big sister would not be quite
so abusive in the exercise of authority
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you your honor my opponent has
outright admitted that the government is
placing surveillance devices on its
citizens including Justice Breyer so I
am shocked the state has argued that
Winston Smith is a member of the
insurgency that must be prevented from
terrorizing Oceania which justifies
depriving him of his civil rights and
then the State argues that he has not
established that his civil rights are
being violated this is exactly the kind
of doublethink that Big Brother has
brought to Oceania that we depend on
this court to put an end to Big Brother
cannot be trusted President Freeman is
nothing but a thinly disguised
incarnation of Big Brother only this
court can protect citizens like Winston
Smith from the draconian abuses of power
that the state has committed here this
court must find for Winston Smith and if
there are no further questions I would
like to conclude because some members of
the audience may have to return home by
Metro safe track
Thank You counsel
thank you
[Music]
the kennel bench will now deliberate
please be seated
brawler honorable bench deliberates our
jury will also decide the cast their
vote by placing a red or a blue token in
the baskets that are being passed along
the question presented for your to
remind you is given the context of war
or threat to national security
should the Oceanian officials named as
defendants and Smith's lawsuit be held
liable for their treatment of Winston
Smith in 1984 again if you think they
should not be held liable you place the
red token and basket if you think they
should be held liable you place the blue
token in the basket again the question
is given the context of war or the
threat to national security
should the Oceania officials named as
defendants be held liable for their
treatment of Winston Smith in 1984 no
for red yes blue
ladies and gentlemen please welcome Abby
David Lowell for tonight's discussion as
is our tradition while the judges
deliberate wanted to make sure that we
could continue the conversation so
please let me bring to the stage person
I've known for a while a great lawyer
and somebody who has insights into the
themes that this book and this play
addresses Ted Boutrous of Gibson Dunn
and Crutcher
is a both trial lawyer advisor about
crises and media events and was one of
the lead lawyers in advising Apple in
the controversy that it has had and is
having with the government namely the
FBI
Ted was involved in litigation in advice
to the company in dealing with the
issues that were both in court in the
media and continue to be so in a play in
a trial about 1984 what more apt and
more relevant can it be than to welcome
to the stage somebody who's living with
George Orwell only imagined Ted Boutrous
so let's start with the first question
I know everybody here knows the issue or
knows of the controversy of Apple versus
FBI but I have actually in my
conversations including my own thoughts
found that it is very misunderstood some
liken it as a case about privacy some
about a taking of the government of
people's property so let's start off by
finally getting the font to tell us what
is the dispute really about well thank
you I mean first thanks for setting the
standard so high that I should be
entertaining by playing myself so I'll
try to rise to the occasion here and I
do appreciate the chance to talk a
little bit about the Apple case we
didn't really think about it as Apple
versus the FBI because it really was the
case raised very important issues about
national security the importance of law
enforcement and at the same time the
privacy and security of citizens and
just a quick recap of what happened
after the tragic events in San
Bernardino in December the government
immediately asked Apple to produce
information that hit had regarding in
the two killers and from from phones
that they had and from other information
and Apple did that it had some in cloud
and in other air it has a policy of
cooperating with the government and
assisting the government in response to
warrants and subpoenas but the
government then went to step farther and
it took the extraordinary step of
seeking an ex parte order from the court
in San Bernardino federal court asking
that the court compel Apple to develop
new software that would destroy the
security protections on one of the
iPhones used by one of the killers which
was protected by a password Apple has
been working it's an arms race to
protect all of our data from hackers
from cyber criminals from terrorists and
one of the more recent features that
Apple had included was a that the kind
of the cherry on top of the security
protocol and protections on the iPhone
is that is your password once you put
your password in that entangles with all
the other security measures and
and certain encrypted data in your phone
in your actual phone cannot be accessed
by anyone who doesn't know the password
including Apple the government didn't
know the password the individual was
dead the the county of riverside whose
phone it was it was the employers phone
didn't know the password and the
government said it needed to get into
that phone and asked the court to do
something extraordinary which was have
Apple send we estimated to be six to ten
engineers into into the lab so to speak
to develop a brand new operating system
that would allow the government to hack
into the phone that would destroy
security protection so it's a little
privacy a little taking it's a little
both it's a little outside both of those
as you were getting ready to argue the
big argument it seems that it's sort of
both blinked and it didn't get to there
so what is the status right now you know
what happened was I had just finished my
moot court getting ready for the hearing
where we're gonna argue these issues and
I came back to my office and my
assistant said the US attorney was on
the phone and and she was and she said
that they might have found a solution
that made apples cooperation or the
assistance unnecessary so they wanted to
cancel the hearing they subsequently
announced that they had developed a
means to get into that particular phone
and then in another case in New York
where a judge had issued a very strong
ruling saying that the separation of
powers precluded a court from from
authorizing a backdoor into the iPhone
that the government could get into and
that that this was not permissible under
the all writs Act what they had had
invoked it's sort of an all-powerful
magic wand that the government could use
to get courts to order private companies
to do whatever they want and now
Congress going to take the ball now that
the controversy is a little bit outside
the courts we well one of things we said
was this is an issue the American people
must decide through their elected
representatives where the the security
and privacy of citizens versus security
and law enforcement and those are all
important issues and those are political
issues policy issues FBI the FBI
director Comey said the same thing these
are issues of policy so I think Apple
and others have called for a commission
and some process because these are
important issues so with your
perspective let me ask you the first
obvious question so in 1949 or
well-presented 1984 many would say what
we live with today is not as bad as he
envisioned some would say it's worse not
only do we have Big Brother or semi Big
Sisters watching us
for example the NSA but as the questions
indicated there's Google and Amazon that
you get on they know exactly what you
bought and what you're thinking of
buying and the place where you buy
clothes for your kids and your hobbies
so with your new perspective what do you
think as bad as Orwell thought better
what do you think I think we're much
better shape than Oceania in 1984 let me
get that on the table I do think there
are big differences so now we have this
information capability and and yes we
all give up certain secrets and privacy
when we voluntarily post things on
Facebook and the like but the difference
and if you look at what ironically is
you'll recall the most famous ad of all
time or one of them was the 1984 ad by
Apple and the theme of it was to break
out of conformity that individualism
would flourish with devices like the
Macintosh then and the iPhone now and
other devices that allow individuals to
communicate and speak and and get their
views of the truth out on the record
where as in Oceania big brother was
using the surveillance tactics to
squelch freedom and to oppress the
citizenry and to change what the truth
and the actual facts are so I think it's
a it's a big difference thank you has
the law regulating government and
private technology and enterprise in the
use of collection of data kept up with
the technology it it really hasn't I
mean if you think about that I mentioned
the all writs Act which was enacted in
1789 and so that was what the government
had to use to try to get the court to
force Apple to write new software to
allow the government to get into devices
and one of the other things we argued
was that would be subject to it would be
a grand prize for hackers to steal that
software so they could then use it and
misuse it for the illicit purposes
but they had to cite a 79 case and then
they relied on a good opinion from 1807
where they claimed a clerk was required
to decipher something on the stand so
that was the law they were relying on to
ask for this really brand new
technological order from the court so I
think the law does need to be looked at
and also I think the law restricting the
government because as you suggested
there is incredible surveillance
techniques that the government now has
immense power we want the government to
be able to use that to protect our
country to protect citizens to go after
terrorists and evildoers and all of that
but at the same time we have different
interests in our country privacy
security so we need the laws to be
revised in a way that checks the
government so we don't start going at
least small steps down the Big Brother
Big Brother Road so as the questions
also projected the bedrock principle of
the Fourth Amendment and the check of
power in that way in the most
traditional constitutional sense is the
expectation of privacy so given what we
now know exists ridging from the nonstop
social media to cameras on every street
corner to the ability of the government
and private enterprise as I said to be
involved every time we turn on our
computer has the expectation of privacy
changed so that the law will now reflect
that we do not any long live in that
kind of place where you shut your doors
you shut your shutters is that one of
the things that now needs to be
addressed and again if that's the case
by court decision or by legislation it
has changed for sure I think we all have
a different expectation of privacy than
we did 20 years ago because of these
technological advances the information
we get we choose to give out but we give
it out in order to participate in these
incredible tools and apps and
technologies and so I do think the
courts will be important and the courts
have done the Supreme Court with new
technologies has applied the Fourth
Amendment in a way that protects privacy
and the sanctity of your home when
drones and other things are being used
but I do think it it has an effect now
we've seen some backlash we saw the the
verdict against Gawker by Hulk Hogan and
I think there was a sense there of a
pushback in terms of something still our
private private but I do think there's
we have to look at it differently and
that was one of the big things in the
appli matter that protecting privacy of
data we all have so much who shal data
on our phone our lives are there that we
need the law to protect that and also we
need to look at these other interests
that are important as well if you had
the ability to tell the Congress that is
looking at this right now the one thing
that they should legislate that would
get the balance right the one thing what
would that one thing be it would be that
there should be encryption to protect at
the end of the line that the balance
should be struck to protect data and not
to give a backdoor to the government
because of all the risks that entails
and it's not just me the defense
secretary during the controversy that we
just went through said end-to-end
encryption is the most important for
security for national security and so I
would start with that premise and there
are competing laws and bills floating on
both sides but start with that premise
and then think about how do we address
these other issues so if this end-to-end
encryption and that remains thank for
saying I take it then that we are ready
to live with the proposition that if the
government can't get at the data through
their means they don't have the power to
compel it by any other means ie
a backdoor that means our system is
built on the fact that at some point we
recognize law enforcement or other
interests give way to other important
and interests like privacy like First
Amendment rights we argued this was a
First Amendment violation forcing
someone to write code to do something
that they strongly believed against was
forced compelled speech and the Supreme
Court has said it many times that our
system our bill of rights exists to say
at some point we will we may not be able
to get every piece of evidence but it's
worth it to give that up and to protect
overriding values and rights so one last
question this is a special audience
that's supporting this special theater
so we can agree among us to keep this to
ourselves
alright alright whoa
when is the iPhone 7 coming out
[Applause]
all rise
please be seated
please welcome back Abbi David Lowell to
read the jury's decision I think I'm
going to defer to the bench first as I
was saying counsels counsels performance
was superb in what was I think this
audience will agree a more difficult
case and is usually presented at the
Shakespeare Theatre mock trials so you
were both excellent
and on the merits the majority has
concluded that this is a very easy case
because if war is peace then we are in
peacetime and there is no excuse for any
of these extraordinary measures
but if I can interject a serious note
the great jurists confronted with the
question suppose the police suspect that
they have apprehended someone who knows
where and when a ticking bomb is going
off can the police use torture to
extract that information the answer was
simple torture never and why because we
could hand our enemies no greater
victory and in our concern for security
we lose all the basic values that make
us a human society
and now I will ask my colleagues on the
bench to add concurring and in one case
a dissenting view so Justice Breyer
first well with my colleague Justice
Ginsburg I agree that's as good an
opinion as I ever did see besides that
she has clout because Ginsburg Jay knows
what she's talking about
and now judgment let I concur in the
judgment in part because I think the
state was is overly excessive in what
it's doing we know it's not necessary if
the goal here is to stop the 1 percent
of people who are terrorists there's
been an alternative plan discussed in
the public and that will be just to tax
the 1% and take all that money to buy
free Hamilton tickets for everybody else
[Applause]
judge Hillard I would say that the
government is not entitled to qualified
immunity qualified immunity does not
apply where the law is established and
because Oceania is omniscient and makes
the law it must know the law whether it
has been announced by any court or not
and our dissenter with all due respect
to my colleagues and of course this
won't be the first time the Supreme
Court has not agreed with me I don't
feel that I'm in a position to decide
this case miss Jeffers and mr. power
each represent clients who have been
rewriting history for decades the
country of Oceania through in its
predecessor through its truth Department
and Winston Smith as a loyal employee of
that department so I have absolutely no
confidence in the record or anything
either of these allies fine lawyers told
us today and as a result I would issue
an order require each of them to submit
within 30 days an affidavit by a person
qualified to testify as to the facts as
to what in what actually happened here
that all decided and now and we have the
jury's verdict so I would Justice
Kennedy I'm sorry Justice Breyer light
to say that in the way this theater has
always given the audience its final say
the tokens represent if you remember
blue for those who believed that the
Oceana officials should be held liable
for their actions against Winston Smith
and the red that no they should not be
held liable
[Applause]
this concludes Winston versus Oceania in
1984 presented funny barred Association
enjoy the rest of your evening
[Applause]
[Music]